how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul well the quran the
app is about to show you
your progress with your soul yes that's
correct not only does it encourage you
to read it tells you how many verses
you've read how many pages you read how
long you've been on it and best of all
the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends
imagine as a muslim if i come and say
the quran is not a perfect book
what would be going through your head
the question that will be going through
your head or should be going through
your head is
well okay you believe this is from god
you don't believe it's to be perfect
it has mistakes in it are you even a
muslim now when i came to islam brothers
and sisters one of the main reasons i
chose islam
was because i said if i am going to
dedicate and follow any religion
it has to be a book that is preserved
and it has evidences that it is from god
it's a basic foundation if it's from god
i need to know and
we prove this from god yeah and if it is
i have to follow it
yeah now someone that you had a dialogue
with um
this speak in speaker's corner said
something very strange and bizarre and
the way he said it is as if
he thought he was doing something good
to uh to his uh
yeah it was like one point for him but
he didn't realize it was like an on goal
let's watch him hear what he had to say
because it was quite bizarre christians
don't teach or believe that the bible
is perfect that is a quranic claim
about the quran so you have to
judge the quran by what the quran says
and the bible by what the bible says
so the bible says it is here to teach
you
about who god is and how to live it
doesn't
claim to be perfect like the corruption
okay so it's very simple yeah anywhere
in the bible does the bible claim that
it's been preserved
no it doesn't it doesn't there's a verse
where it says if if you change one joke
god will
punish you etc but it does not say it's
been preserved so we're going to judge
the bible by the bible and his
statements
that the bible doesn't claim to be
preserved okay the quran is the quran
claim to be preserved
yeah okay what does the quran say it
says
that certainly we will send down we have
sent down the
reminder and we will preserve it okay
well hold on a second but is there a
challenge there to prove
it's easy to say but is there challenges
that allah gives there are many
challenges that the quran gives in fact
it's good to ask this question because
it would seem that there are two
categories of things which are required
in order to prove
a word is from god right that are
necessary and sufficient okay okay yeah
so necessary are like the basic
requirements that if you don't so
if you don't fulfill those um
necessary requirements then you we can't
even have a conversation about the book
being from god
and i would say among the most necessary
conditions
that are required in order for a book to
be from god not only just preservation
but i would say
lack of inconsistencies and this is what
the quran actually mentions in chapter
number four verse number 82
where it mentions
if it was from other than god they would
have found in it many different areas
in contradictions right now the thing is
because
it's not a uncommon thing for a
christian
apologist like him or a christian
scholar to say
that the bible is um has errors in it
in fact carl bar who is one of the major
scholars
um in the 20th century he referred to
the bible as vulnerable
other people like him you know have also
said that the bible
they don't uphold what is referred to as
the principle or the
the the creed of biblical inerrancy
most people that definitely do uphold
this would be evangelical
but others don't especially in the
modern age where you can
you can literally materially see the
mistakes in the bible whether it's
historical mistakes whether it's
um textual mistakes or whether it's
contradictions
scientific mistakes anything right and
so
what happened in this discussion is that
i was pushing him on
some of the internal contradictions in
the bible and he came to the conclusion
that
well we don't need to say the bible is
perfect now what i'm saying is
why should we believe that a book with
contradictions is the word of god
and that's a very important question to
be asked brothers and sisters because
when we discuss
i spoke to a lot of christians when they
realize and come to the realization hold
on a second i cannot defend this book
anymore and we see that in speaker's
corner
where the christians who come to the
park
they have actually stopped talking about
the bible they do not talk about the
trinity
yeah all they're doing is talking about
islam now one wonders i'm a muslim
if i don't talk about tahit who's going
to talk about tawheed so when you come
into the park and all you're doing is
talking about islam
and not your book that asks a big
question now that big question mark is
answered with your words this individual
the book is not perfect now if the book
is not perfect
and you're telling me that this is the
book that we know the resurrection and
the crucifixion and the trinity
hold on a second you're basing your life
on jesus divinity his crucifixion and
his resurrection on the book that is not
perfect
well how can we we're asking a question
how do we how can we trust that the
resurrection and the divinity
and his uh his his death or whatever it
may be his divinity
are perfect because he's coming from an
imperfect book brothers and sisters if i
when i say this
our christian brothers when i speak to
them i go look you
you care about your body your well-being
okay if i gave you a bottle of water and
i said look just a drop of poison just a
little bit drop
drink it you will never drink it how are
you putting
your soul at risk by consuming a book
that is not perfect
not only not perfect it's the severity
of imperfection as well
like let's say the parts of the book
which are imperfect
to what extent are they imperfect to
what extent are they erroneous they may
be so imperfect that they may be guiding
you astray and what kind of book
from god would guide somebody astray and
why would a book from god
have imperfections in it when it says
that god is not meant to be the author
of confusion
yes and this is the point like at the
end of the day
if god wanted it if how could god punish
me
for following a book which is imperfect
exactly following a book which is
fulfilled with contradictions exactly
and it's just it just seems hijab to me
bro it just seems
observing speaking to our christian
brothers and sisters is that they have
totally lost
absolute hope well it was first it was a
trinity and the training could be
discussed using the bible
yeah now they're saying that the very
trinity that we used to discuss using
the bible we're not even using the bible
anymore
i hear statements as like this the
following we don't need the bible
we have christ i've heard the statements
many times
what do you mean you it's like me saying
i don't need the quran
um i will i have allah how are you going
to know allah
his attributes who he is if you don't
have the quran exactly
i don't think there's much to say um
there's really not much to say
and this shows you why self-sabotaging
it's it's it's an intellectual suicide
it's as simple as that
yeah it's a yanni they're making our
case for us
yeah and i think this this this coward
this is helping us out yeah he's an
intellectual eunuch
yeah uh he is he is he is he is an
intellectual coward he's somebody who
comes to the park
over and over again and you know why you
can see you know when i look at his face
you can see
the the the the darkness in his face
every time he comes to the park here
all he does is just talk about islam
yeah
and i you know i understand the moment
he spoke about the bible he gave us
everything we needed
exactly and that's why he doesn't like
speaking about it can you imagine if
this guy can
you imagine he spoke about the bible
before what was it under one minute yeah
can you speak with 10 minutes
oh yeah that's what's going on
you're going through the bible on the
bus you throw everyone in the bar so
brothers and sisters
um in a nutshell for christian brothers
and sisters who are genuinely watching
this we're talking about this specific
individual because it's hostile towards
us yeah
and allah tells us that you guys are not
all the same but for those who are
genuinely seeking
one more thing know that just to make a
claim of that we're not here to
you know we're laughing at this
individual if you're generally looking
for the truth this does not make you
question it bro one more thing actually
i've done this video on my channel
and so i'm gonna i'm gonna read
something out
some that someone has said this is okay
william lane craig
who's seen as a premier apologist of the
christian world and a scholar
and he takes the same view as bob and so
many things listen to what he says yeah
he says the author of genesis seems
utterly unconcerned
to iron out the inconsistencies between
chapter one
and chapter two that commentators have
struggled with for centuries
he does not seem to care that they're
inconsistent
the author an attitude suggests of an
intended non-literal interpretation
so basically his way to solve the
problem of contradictions in the bible
is to say all of it is a metaphor but my
question would be what is the use
of contradictory metaphors exactly yeah
this is a good question
yeah yeah my sisters hope you enjoyed
the video next till next time assalamu
alaikum
is